[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui se passe
vous allez devoir faire demi-tour il ya
un grave accident là bas et on peut
faire quelque chose si vous êtes médecin
peut-être pas tout bien je lis poupée ça
c'est vous qui le dites
[Musique]
ça a marché de demeurer maîtrise et
comment tu as pu ne pas me dire que tu
perdais la fideua rennes ce soir on sera
de retour deux bonnes heures demain
matin
bonne soirée est ce que tes parents
gardent des trucs flippant chez vous une
guerre tout enfermé dans une caisse
il vaut mieux que personne entre là
dedans
verdi que tout ce qui est à l'intérieur
et soit hanté soit envoûté ou été
utilisés dans des pratiques rituelles
c'est qui le passeur on mettait des
pièces sur les yeux des morts pour
qu'ils prennent leur âme
c'est quoi cette poupée annabelle l
enfermer pour une bonne raison
[Musique]
non
annabelle appelle d'autres esprits
[Musique]
noté mme warren maman ou est-ce que tout
va bien qu'il se passe quelque chose
dans votre maison et on sait vraiment
pas ce qu'il faut faire
je peux parler à annabelle excusez moi
[Musique]